i think the steve pick is great you know
steve naturally has been so good against
mishimas you know the ability to kind of
restrict things they can do especially
with things like you know one two one
and back one that that is the killer
there back one is the ability of the
keep out for back one to beat out not
only the electric and god fist but also
to beat out the hell sweep it really
kind of changes the perspective on the
approach and there's the back one
beating out the dashes
i i hate to call it out that way but
that be like that sometimes
yeah asking you shall receive and now
cousin
following that up that back one with a
low parry combo he's putting himself on
the highlight reel parkman
who's in his cruising right now with
steve the way that he's kind of uh just
playing the textbook style that you want
to do against mashimas is not let them
get in get those punishers that you need
and just kind of outpace them with your
your offense oh big counter hit there
with the wall standing too he's going to
push towards the wall this is going to
hurt
yeah it's just so much damage coming off
the back and we see cascade already on
the back foot here does get the splat
going while the wall here spends the
drive we're seeing devil kazuya
can't even use it though exercise the
devil that's steve fox yeah he's not a
boxer he's a he's an exorcist
yep
and right now things have been working
out but the rain is starting to pour
here in this opening match
let's see what adjustments casey is
going to make because right now he
hasn't really found any way to get in
offensively and look he hit him with a
sidestep 311 able to land that's a
natural combo of course
let's see what he does how is he gonna
adjust here
and you know the strength
so far
we've left and sidestep left beats out
naturally beats out a lot of the
mishima's attacks the only thing that
could really be so smart it is a dash
electric the dash electric can hit but
because it's high there might not be an
opportunity for it to hit cleanly
great that's very true you see that he's
just constantly moving and he sniped out
that low all cousin it's all coming up
cousin dang
tex textbooks wise that was such a
brilliant uh kind of game plan going
into it the the the duck left the side
step left and
knowing that he can't hit him with a
high or maybe a deep dash he went for
the hell sweep there but he was able to
throw in the ducks in between that
timing to really block and capitalize
and you know he only hit him with the
wall setting one too if he blocks that
health he could launch him he could take
him to the other side of the stage and
you know that as we've seen that could
be like 40 to 50 off your life bar
depending on the combo that you do but
man great game plan going into this and
case k he's put into a tough position
here what is he gonna do
that's tough because he's only he's just
using uh the mishima i think he could
just back maybe
just play the poke game but you're going
against steve and it just seems like
kuzin just found the timing round start
back one uh did not land a single hell
sweep always was ready for the blocked
low punish with a wild man it just seems
like
who's in really did his homework
yeah you know i'm gonna say there's a
way that he can win but it's it forces
the gameplay to be very very dry right
so there's certain moves that work
generally very well against steve it's
like you know doing dash of generic
downforce it's doing things like yes low
jabs at certain times and it's it's kind
of
outpacing him and and out timing him and
you know steve has a lot of tools that
can really dominate the matchup we were
talking about back one and one two one
earlier on however if you force them to
whiff there are opportunities very small
windows where where kazuya can come out
on top and get the right hit that he
needs but again that's gonna be a tall
order considering the the control level
that we saw from kuzen so far so case
case really has his work cut out for him
let's see what he's able to do as we go
into this rematch right now
it was uh it was three rounds straight
for kuzin so let's see what he does here
as we get into this
yeah and he's running it back in
dragon's nest so he does want these
walls but yeah see this is actually what
you mentioned yeah downforce yeah he's
going to keep it kind of safe kind of
dry for now until he gets his footing in
this matchup but uh cousin though oh wow
just trying to interrupt him as he's
trying to push him towards the wall but
again the movement from cousin he just
knows when casey is coming in and look
at him he's constantly like moving
constantly staying away from that the
threat blocks the low to the wild man
now he's not like he has a huge life
lead now
yeah it's it's it's oh here we go
there's the hell suit that he wants now
see once he's gets put in the blender
there's no way for steve to really kind
of counteract other than guessing right
mm-hmm
so okay he got that low
oh
wow yeah but but sometimes that's the
telltale
once they start blocking the hell swoops
that's a completely different tell so he
has an opportunity still but again
sometimes collecting the data you got to
do it early on and we've talked about it
so many times the health street is
something that you live by and you die
by
he might have to yeah make those gambles
come out and probably not even throw
caution to the wind to throw off the
rhythm and the the reeds of kuzin so far
so good on the side of cascade oh he's
gonna break that guard with that blue
stuff pushing towards the wall now with
cruz and bullying him gets him out of
the hell sweep state pushing against the
wall
now just slowly just dissecting the
health and cousin five round straight
can he make it six fight oh man i mean i
liked what he was going for there but
right now kuzin is on fire the way that
he is approaching the matchup he's
really taking apart the game's the
playstyle from k that casey is
comfortable with
normally normally wouldn't be able to
sidestep it the way that he did but look
at that 10-count throw
mm-hmm
running
yeah still in favor of all the
yeah twin pistons launch
now this could be the momentum shift
that we're looking for case gate finally
puts one on the board for
i'm himself we really haven't seen use
of the wall standing one plus two from
kazuya either i know it's it's not it's
not really a move that you can just
throw out willy-nilly but i feel like on
wake up at least the way he dashes in
and tries to create opportunities it's a
move that could net him some positive
here oh my god he's so good with that
the guard break
oh but look at that oh i wasn't able to
get more out of it and now we see that
case keep fighting with his back against
the wall he just needs one big launch
rising four follow that up with a steel
pedal final round mark man
that was a huge risk there he went with
the mid and then able to able to pay off
right now casey
looking for that opportunity the big
sidestep that was huge oh
just get some jabs playing a little
conservatively and cousins gonna rack up
a huge uh life lead here
who's in is so sick
oh my gosh speaking of sick my stomach
yeah just hold that for me while we see
the case case and rage uh oh below the
belt now we're seeing him kill the
electric he's hella dead yes he is
helicopter wow
case k
flipping the script here no we're not
moving on just yet we're taking a 1-1
we're gonna take this all the way to the
third match it's the best of three
you know what's crazy i felt like casey
lost every single round even though he
won the match i felt like he lost every
single round but it came down to the
clutch moments at the very end whether
it was that down forward one into the
follow-up with the steel pedal or that
clutch electric when god fist
he he definitely was on the verge of
losing but he pushed it out at the very
end
yeah
the game plan right the game plan that
kuzen brought to the table looked like
it was it was something that was just
locked and loaded undefeatable right no
way for for casey to get in but he made
it work he made it work towards the very
end and he was able to still kind of
play his style and take those big risks
and make them count
and just to highlight what you said
right the way he won those it really
went down to the wire so it seemed like
he really had to go through a lot just
to get that game plan going and i think
that that goes with that
i guess he turned up his playstyle of
conserve being conservat conservative so
like he brought it up a little bit but
you saw him take a little more risk with
those health sweeps you saw him take a
little more risk to just go in like that
so it's going to be quite tough and this
victory will be well earned if he's able
to get it so let's see how casey will
try to maintain this lead but you know
what kuzin can still adjust he still has
uh he's still got levels to steve
yeah
again there's i think this this matchup
can evolve a bit more you know there's a
lot of things that we really haven't
seen from ksc yet i saw him go for the
standing four counter hit once in the
match up and he wasn't able to pull it
off but that kind of shows you that he's
looking for ways to kind of bait things
out there's a while standing one plus
two that we haven't really seen from him
as well which has some admirable
tracking
uh and just the ability to kind of get
in and create these opportunities you
know he landed a big risk there with
that wall standing too kind of test his
opponent so let's see what he does now
using the forward four oh and this time
the election lands its mark he's gonna
get the wall as well it's gonna hurt
okay big damage coming on the early
rounds still maintaining the lead is
cascade now moving away he doesn't want
his back against the wall you see the
constant movement from both these
players who's in oh gets hit by the hell
sweep and the forward 4k skate finally
in the lead
fight yeah and what a way to kind of
turn things around oh he caught him on
the on the get up the follow up here
he's gonna get the ball this is gonna
hurt again
okay nice patience there by casey not
waking up right away but look at that
the wake up three the wake up low who's
in trying to go for that massage in the
wall but no casey now realigning himself
oh my god mark man my gut
yeah great adjustment there look at the
damage
oh oh
okay is playing out of control but nice
he did it backward albatross to avoid
that final sequence that was pretty sick
except this wasn't enough
yeah i just went for that down four so
far it's all been cascade
who's in now in the back foot here gets
the low parry but he wasn't able to get
much out of it casey still chopping away
at the legs
[Music]
is betting at all he's trying to get
that extended duck one try to catch him
ducking but you know casey is not going
for it casey is not gonna risk it all on
a duck
yeah oh okay probably electric attempt
but now we see cousin though
finds the wall
this time he didn't get through this
combo there
what's he gonna do he's
you know looking at that first match and
the way cousin controlled it there was
no way that i would have
between matches put money down on casey
but casey
definitely
definitely buckled down deep and he made
it happen for himself so i got to give
it up that is a brilliant sequence of
events that really led to his victory
and for him to continue his tournament
streak because right now kuzin is out of
the tournament unfortunately at seventh
place so i got to give it up some great
play that we've seen from kuzen and good
steve of course uh good double chin that
we saw earlier as well but unfortunately
out of the tournament now and cascade
and his kazuya will be moving on
yeah and and look